[Music]
hi Doris Mike how's it going okay cool
good to see you man so man how are you
doing Dori welcome to the performance
capture stage hey what are you hey you
know this guy
so probably nice to meet you Dorian a
big fan Thanks Dorian perform with you
today Mike hey Dorian nice to meet you
Dorian there's like there were a lot of
really beautiful sets in Austin yeah
shooting this isn't one of them this is
a build of a virtual set so on the
monitor beside Robert you can see it's a
one-to-one representation of this
digital set that we've built you see I
Ahlan way in the back and he is there he
is he's Missy Anna and the reason we
build all this out is so that the actor
can interact with this set and he it
gives him somewhere to work God you know
rather than just a blank space you can
move through this space and he
understands where he is in it so here
comes Allen Missy Anna moving through
the space oh dang yeah so if you stand
on those yellow feet and spin around as
the camera swings around you can look in
this monitor here as the camera swings
around see this pipe and not pipe and
here comes crew ishka so Mike's playing
a 10 foot tall Grishka mm-hmm
on set Robert can have these guys
interact with one another and they'll do
stunt choreography today we've built a
little offset into their performance and
I'm gonna show you what that is if you
stand next to Robert
they look like they're right in front of
each other even though they're standing
this far apart yeah so the Allen can
kick that pad and he'll hit Ike here so
he can kick it as hard as one not hurt
him so in physical space we've kind of
moved them apart with a digital space we
can make them all kind of line line up
to one another
yeah they're interesting things to eye
lines so she's looking up there at the
blue marker it sort of be the height of
Grishka and he's always looking at this
ground marker but see it there looks
like they're looking at each other so we
figure out all those eye lines yeah cuz
when Rosa was acting with Jackie Earle
Haley he's 10 feet tall in the movie but
so she couldn't look at him she had to
look up at a marking above him and he
had to look down in the ground and you
this was a sword so this is a set that
was replicated from Austin yeah it's
very similar to the underground set for
the scene okay yeah so there was like
like all sorts of physical builds that
you will have seen in that fly over
yesterday and some of the images but
like this is more of a virtual stage for
a virtual CG set and you do performance
capture in both types of sets so today
we're gonna do a little bit of a fight
you're gonna take take out him you're
gonna fight Ike here yeah the offsets
you'll really be beating this up okay
yeah and the film it'll look like you're
taking him down yeah step over here
we'll show you how it's done first let's
see what you look like so you step here
you'll see Oh was wrong knife-hand no
can move all the way up into the flame
good in front of that flaming Beryl you
see how you interactive lighting even
works like that anyway what's going on
there in your chest so you got like
missing chest cavity and you've got the
intuiting tattoos and scars and face
that's been stitched together
so that's your body language is gonna be
important so you're gonna want to see
how his arms are now now give it a
little more swagger but you chin up a
little more and just walk in that's okay
see so that works good for him just
physically we wanted to tell when he's
walking through here that he's
intimidating that he's a predator and
that even if this big guy shows up he
can take you that is even the subtleties
that'll work so you can even be very
subtle in your movement as long as your
attitude is right that's the performance
we're trying to capture now the
interesting thing about performance
capture is you can play a little tiny
character or a big huge cyborg right or
that or this guy will do yeah exactly
and whatever you put into it is gonna
come off and translate one-to-one into
into that guy right in there this is
also I mean you got a little beat up
right yeah all right so today we're
gonna do you you saw were Alan walk down
he's gonna you're gonna walk down
through the environment as you get up
towards here Ike's gonna come out of
that pipe and then you're gonna you're
gonna couple punches am i punching this
yeah Alan will show you how you do it
yeah a couple punches couple kicks and
you're gonna take him down all right
yeah man yeah so yeah I'm come forward
onto the green mark here so yeah for the
offset this is your eye line for gross
because here I'm trying to hit the swing
at that so for the car goofy will do
like a right and then a lift so he throw
I like a huge right kind of hammock boom
yeah you can really put your body into
it - really that's it Wham one of those
and then if you want to come back with
this be mean old knife hand yeah exactly
yeah yeah one of those one of those nice
yeah and he's still a big dude so this X
lines up with his kneecap yeah so if you
give that a good little pop that's gonna
take his knee out yeah cool yeah and you
can yeah as comfortable as you as you
feel all right cool so one of those
takes him down to his knee and then his
chest is about this high as well so you
can kind of wind up and finish him off
with another boomer straight to the
chest you told my mom yeah he's down if
he's got enough but a life lift and I'm
still maybe you could smash him over the
head with I don't know one of these
really heavy rocks Wham yeah well my
money fool yes okay and if Mike's not up
on his mark when you throw that rock
near it's gonna bounce off nothing okay
because
oh wow when it comes time to fight
you've got time between each hit to
really look at him and see how he's
feeling you don't have to blitz your way
through it okay yeah so that one too
yeah that days is them and then when you
take out that [ __ ] you gonna kick that
if you could sell more of it in your
body
you know it'll just feel stronger yeah
when he's standing that's his Island
once you've taken out his knee he's down
here
okay so first we've got to get him in
the book gotta hit him a couple times in
the head take him down
and once he's down once he's here
they've got the look all right and yeah
and if he's still going get some rocks
and rocks take that and then yeah
victory dance well you know a nice
little victory pose at the end like used
to smoke I'm ready you feeling I'm
feeling it all right some live score six
yeah you're the boss so you you know
he's down it you're coming down here to
fight always get you hit on us so I'm
going up there yeah yeah come up there
with you it's on an angle to match our
virtual rule Wow and in the virtual
world this exists but this doesn't this
is just for safety okay cool
but like you see it you're the boss
you're not scared but you know used
anything all right
yeah well feel free to be vocal it's
that would have really no I'm not gonna
curse I'm good that's because I okay
cool and action
[Music]
that's fine mom until one [ __ ] you go
oh there is
what a fan all right
[Music]
scroll cut beautiful oh good let's check
it out that's actually really good I
don't see how the swagger is to see how
the movements are I like to slow to down
at the beginning which is cool yeah look
at this writers great see you're playing
a character now yeah look at that don't
know where you're swinging your arms
around just feels like you own the place
you don't care you're not afraid that's
me that's cool that's cool that's
everything you did it's capturing your
performance that's what this is all
about I see what happen to me lands now
here yeah it was scared like yeah
whatever here at the end it feels like
the physical movements thank you okay
starting with when he jumps out yeah
it's cool that you're stoic and you know
react but since he's not really here mhm
then go ahead and sell it all more just
step back I love it just like that and
then come in and when you throw the
punches go ahead and wind up a little
more it'll just feel more powerful all
right all the hits and even that and
even the rock we could feel heavier rain
throw it open it'll just feel like
there's more power behind it everything
else is great thank you all right man
all right
nice what I think this time I'll follow
you okay cool yeah
[Music]
so yeah just more of the same brother
you're king of the street I'll just
follow you like your hype man at all no
you
hold up no oh my lord
[Laughter]
all right
join you get up there I'm good okay okay
and action
[Music]
[Music]
I'll shake it here you know I can't walk
away yeah it's dating character all in
the end performance capture might be now
my new passion
hello man I'm good pretty much oh okay
look at that swagger that's the best
swagger yeah yeah that's the best
swagger of anybody you guys a little
extra man in the shoulders really sells
the
[Music]
so cool Wow thank you this is awesome
so this is a virtual camera and I'm
filming you as you're moving through
that what you just saw was him filming
through even though you didn't see him
here it's cuz he was off to the side
doing that oh wow so I can be flown
around anywhere yeah I can put the
camera anywhere now the interesting
thing about this is that once we get
your performance once we captured you we
send it to Robert and tomorrow next week
next month he can pull it up and you can
cover it however you want and get a
bunch of other different shots though
that wasn't the shot that's gonna be in
the movie I can I like that attitude you
have beginning I'm gonna start closer on
you and just follow you around and I can
do that without you being here because
we already got your performance so I get
all kinds of shots at you that you don't
remember us ever getting so that which I
did a lot of with uh with Rosa yeah we
captured them and then we did that for a
year
yeah you know put new shots finished it
out lit it the way we want got all the
right light in her eye whatever she did
that we really liked we responded to
that and shot it later oh they're pretty
cool like the virtual camera was just
something y'all decided after what you
started filming a little bit or was this
something y'all already had planned I'm
gonna plan to use it for certain
sequences that we weren't gonna have any
sets and both of them are completely CG
that's the place to use it for other
places where we had real sets that we're
gonna build there gonna be other actors
we would build a partial set but then
totally CG environments like the
underground point that's like there's
nothing to shoot we just got to capture
their performance doing the action and
then we got to build all that stuff so
they're jumping all around that place
flying in the air and we get in all
their facial performance so right now we
consecrating just on your performance we
shot this for real in a set it would
have taken us all day to do this because
we would have had to shoot every section
relight get a new camera angle we would
have to get the camera and the
performance really quickly right here we
can just do performance so you just do
the performance so like you say if you
wanted to get something else like so you
do something virtually you go back and
you can film it actually like after you
see oh this is the this is what I want
anything and we got a better performance
from you because you're not having to
split your performance up across the day
for us ever every little piece of it
you got you doing it all in one so it's
you know fluid and you've got an
attitude going the whole time gosh
you're gonna continuity to it so it's
really just concentrating only on
performance yeah they're big part of
performance is facial we're not doing
facial today but onset Rosa would be
wearing the helmet and the face rig I
use this template to put dots on her
face in the same spot every day so the
canvas he picked up the emotions yeah
then we track it with the two cameras so
we can get all the subtleties of your
face movement when you punch something
so you don't do them you don't do that
just with rows or just any anybody
that's mom we did it with Jackie - we
get it with gelda so yeah and the great
thing about it is that we're getting
your facial and your body performance on
one go because those things are really
linked and to get a true performance you
want to get both of those things at the
same time I'm not gonna lie like if we
did if I had that on me the wall is
doing that y'all probably would get like
a oscar-nominated kind of freed up more
yeah the cameras not on you filming you
you you're filming this guys you know
I'm free I'm just doing whatever the
pajamas just do yeah exactly because
they get me in like a front of a regular
camera I tighten up Phillip who was this
kid but being able to be out here doing
it and going through the motions they
really like I feel like yeah I could be
an actor now or something yeah you can
see how people say that oh that this
method must be really restricting to an
actor it's like the opposite it's really
freeing they all get really freed up in
there thanks for coming to the bone
thank you sir
selfie with you yeah selfie with
yourself or we can take it for you with
you so if you unlock that I can take a
shot of you oh you know I'll try to get
you with your character I think I turn
it to the wrong way all right so you can
strike a pose move in there yeah and
here there's these other guys yeah
they're in there too cool nice one door
thank you so much thank you guys for all
of this very awesome Hey
I just want to say big I'm from Texas as
well from Austin so from Austin from
Austin yeah I've been there since the
sauce my kids all of this life is all of
that in Sharkboy and Lavagirl watching
those are my movies and to be here like
getting coached by you is something I
never thought I'd be able to use for
kicking ass for us